there's a new royal baby that's exciting
news come on here's the real news but
here's the real news thanks to the Royal
baby today was the first time in a long
time that the breaking news was not
about Donald Trump thank you yeah which
is weird yeah which is weird because
usually the hashtag royal baby is about
Donald Trump that's a little strange
what's going on a video a video out
there a former President Obama making
Melania Trump smile has gone viral
yeah no it's historic the first time a
president has brought joy to Melania
that's him that's him watching this show
right now I don't like it here's a loser
yeah
Hannity looks weird tonight yeah this is
it handed a change watch out oh so
you've trumped the Department of Justice
released James commis memos last week
yeah according to James commis memos
over dinner
president Trump vigorously denied that
he spent a night in Moscow during the
2013 Miss Universe pageant denied it
yeah which is weird cuz all Comey asked
him was can you pass the salt that was
weird
mrs. strange President Trump tweeted
that he may pardon someone because
Sylvester Stallone asked him to yeah
yeah the pardons for the guy who wrote
Rocky 5 he was sentenced to death he was
on death row one term at me check out
Rocky 5 and you won't be mad at me
anymore
today in the Bill Cosby trial the
defense rested yeah and for once Cosby
had nothing to do with it this is the
kind of show you've come to you don't
you don't play rough in the UK we play
rough here the man with the world what
the hell I'm talking to then we don't
have to have a giant camera three inches
away from them everyone's - he's talking
to him we already had another girl I've
never seen you work this hard in your
life
[Applause]
was I
James
I've traveled the world with James we've
been everywhere together right Haiti
everywhere we've been all over the world
I've never seen him move like that two
women from the UK I'm on it
you